c'est le jour de vérité comme le titre
j'étais en train de dire j'aime bien
j'aime bien ce titre c'est vraiment la
deuxième étape en fait de cette grève
qui dure finalement depuis maintenant le
mois de janvier donc moi je trouve la
stratégie des syndicats assez
intéressante et j'ai assez envie de dire
que pour l'instant ils n'ont pas commis
d'erreurs dans le sens où ils ont
l'opinion avec eux ce qui est
fondamental ils sont unis ce qui est
très rare et en plus de ça les
mobilisations pour l'instant ce sont
bien passées avec on a vu des formes
d'innovation de modernité d'aller le
samedi de pas embêter les gens pendant
les vacances c'est très nouveau tout ça
bon on a quand même en face un
gouvernement qui tient pour l'instant on
a vu Elizabeth born hier et c'est pour
ça que c'est intéressant de dire jour de
vérité c'est que maintenant c'est comme
le bras de fer où on en est enfin on est
presque à égalité qui va l'emporter on
est un tournant aujourd'hui
oui on va voir si effectivement ça peut
basculer d'un côté ou de l'autre
on va voir ce qui va se passer moi je
reste persuadé que
seul ceux qui peuvent défiler des fils
et que c'est toujours les mêmes depuis
la nuit des temps toujours les syndiqués
les syndicats les la fonction publique
et que c'est eux qui bloquent le pays on
est toujours dans un mode assez
traditionnel à la française dont on peut
se lasser et qui est vraiment très
pénible parce que rien ne peut changer
dans notre pays aucune réforme peut se
faire sans que et bien on dise toujours
que les Français sont hostiles on n'en
sait rien il y a des sondages qui nous
disent effectivement que il y a beaucoup
de Français qui veulent pas travailler
plus longtemps je ne sais pas qui veut
travailler plus longtemps j'en connais
pas moi personnellement mais il y a
aussi des Français qui sont responsables
et qui savent que si on travaille pas
plus longtemps et ben de toute manière
c'est tout droit la flèche et évidente
c'est le système par capitalisation et
là c'est pas 2 millions de personnes que
vous aurez dans la rue et encore on les
a pas parce qu'on en a qu'un million
vous en aurez
15 millions parce qu'il y a des gens qui
ont pas les moyens d'aller à la
capitalisation mais vous dites pour vous
que les syndicats en tout cas les gens
qui défilent ne sont pas forcément
représentatifs de lancement mais
vraiment pas ils ont un discours qui est
un discours d'opposition on est toujours
dans notre pays dans la culte dans la
graviculture et dans l'opposition
frontale et jamais jamais donc consensus
alors on va nous dire mais le
gouvernement refuse de parler mais c'est
pas vrai regardez le gouvernement a reçu
les formations syndicales ça fait 7 ans
et alors le gouvernement a commis des
fautes hein comme idée fautes énormes
mais ça fait 6 ans qu'on tourne autour
du pot et qu'on sait très bien qu'il
faudra une réforme des retraites ben
voilà on en est là moi j'apporterai
quand même une petite nuance c'est que
j'ai l'impression de ce que je vois sur
le terrain qui a quand même d'autres
gens que d'habitude qui manifeste je
prends un exemple moi dans mon quartier
des restaurateurs qui vous disent
aujourd'hui tout ça la grève etc bon
c'est très rare pour moi ça on a vu
aussi pendant les dernières
mobilisations en province notamment les
coiffeurs nous on a été voir aussi des
brasseurs c'est pas pour moi la
classique les transports la CGT cheminot
ou RATP je trouve que c'est un peu plus
large est-ce que nous aussi les enquêtes
d'opinion et ce qui est très intéressant
à mon sens c'est que ce ne sont pas que
les catégories populaires qui qui ne
veulent pas travailler plus et c'est ça
qui est très nouveau c'est notamment
dans ma génération des gens des cadres
et je pense que le covid a beaucoup joué
c'est à dire que en fait on a remis le
travail à une autre place on a compris
qu'en fait faire du pain chez soi ou
avoir un extérieur et profiter de la vie
c'est aussi important finalement qu'une
carrière et que je crois que cette
réforme elle est un peu à contretemps
pour toutes ces raisons-là et c'est ce
qu'on entend en tout cas dans les
cortèges les gens qui manifestent ils
vous disent pas seulement on veut pas
travailler deux ans de plus il vous
disent il y a des inégalités dans ce
pays pourquoi c'est au plus pauvre ou
ceux qui n'ont que le travail de les
combler et pas les plus riches pourquoi
on ne s'occupe pas du réchauffement
climatique etc etc donc je crois que
c'est plus un enjeu presque de société
que simplement le fait de pas vouloir
aller à cette réforme ça va au-delà de
cette réforme
qu'elle me fasse du pain
dans la vision du travail ou pas il y a
une autre vision du travail mais
effectivement il y a une autre vision du
travail mais je peux vous dire que si on
vous coupe les retraites ou
si on n'arrive plus à financer ce régime
de solidarité que c'est un régime qui a
été inventé justement pour la solidarité
entre génération si on met à terre tout
ça si on n'arrive pas à le financer si
on n'arrive pas à le réformer je dirais
même que c'est presque l'esprit national
qui est en danger parce que bah on sera
plus que jamais dans un individualisme
forcené qui peut se permettre de faire
une retraite par capitalisation tous les
petits salaires tous les des gens qui
qui gagnent des salaires très modestes
et ben c'est une difficulté pour eux je
parle pas des fonctionnaires ils ont la
Préfon ça fait longtemps qu'ils l'ont la
Préfon qui est un des systèmes les plus
étonnants qui puisse exister puisque
c'est une retraite pour les
fonctionnaires mais par capitalisation
en plus vous parler de cette
mobilisation un peu différente ces gens
que vous voyez manifester qu'une
manifestaient pas avant la mobilisation
qui est important dans les petites
villes et dans les îles moyennes Fabien
Ricard nous emmène à Annonay en Ardèche
c'est la ville dont Olivier du soft a
été maire socialiste pendant 9 ans et
beaucoup d'habitants ont du mal à
digérer qu'il soit aujourd'hui et en
charge de défendre cette réforme on
regarde
à 50 ans Rachel de voyons enchaîne les
contrats précaires cet habitant
d'Annonay est très remontée contre la
réforme des retraites j'ai une carrière
longue j'ai commencé à travailler
j'avais 15 ans et demi me voir
travailler jusqu'à 64 ans c'est pas
possible son temps partiel en CDD dans
une grande surface ne lui permettra pas
de manifester ce mardi mais en
croirachell c'est toute la ville qui est
derrière la mobilisation j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup de collègues qui regrettent de
pas pouvoir aller manifester qui ont
qu'une envie y être quoi
au marché d'Annonay il n'y a pas grand
monde pour défendre le projet de réforme
du gouvernement une réforme pourtant
portée par un enfant du pays Olivier du
soft ministre du Travail et ancien maire
de la ville moi je suis très déçu d'une
personne comme Olivier du sol qui était
mère d'Annonay tout le monde
s'aperçoit que en fait c'est un traître
c'est un traître il était a priori de
gauche j'ai vu le vu le comportement du
gouvernement maintenant on a basculé à
droite à droite toute dans cette ville
de 16000 habitants les manifs ont fait
le plein 5500 personnes pour la dernière
journée de mobilisation selon les
gendarmes accusé de traîtrise par les
manifestants Olivier du soft ne peut
s'en prendre qu'à lui-même pour se
retraité de la CGT il faut savoir où il
habite c'est pas il est grand il est
adulte
d'être ministre du Travail
ultra majoritaire dans le bassin
d'emploi la CGT fourbit ses armes pour
la journée du 7 mars Nicolas et ses
camarades termine leur tournée
d'affichage ils assument leur stratégie
taper sur l'ancien maire
sur Annonay ça a beaucoup marché et
l'idée l'idée c'est de faire la fête à
dupe montrer à dupe que son projet de
loi de retraite on en report et de moins
en moins bienvenu dans sa ville natale
je suis faible
sur batterie au local de la CFDT aussi
on prépare la mobilisation de mardi
voilà maintenant
Gérard janvier responsable historique de
l'union locale fait lui aussi partie des
nombreux déçus de l'ancien maire de la
ville pour certains d'entre nous c'est
toujours un ami quoi si ce n'est que Ben
nos chemins des moments donnés notamment
sur ce problème des retraites et ben il
divergent complètement quoi on a
quelqu'un qui a vrai et qui a apporté
pour le développement économique du
territoire et qui aujourd'hui se
retrouve à défendre une retraite
défendre l'indéfendable quoi mais Gérard
et ses camarades ne cautionne pas pour
autant les attaques contre la personne
d'Olivier du soft d'ailleurs ici pas
d'Inter syndicale CGT et CFDT marcheront
en ordre dispersés l'objectif c'est que
le projet de réforme soit
soit retiré mais c'est pas de faire
campagne compte monsieur du stop
aujourd'hui les ministres du travail
demain ce sera quelqu'un d'autre mais le
projet sera toujours là donc c'est
vraiment le projet que on se bat contre
le projet mais pas contre une personne
contactez le maire socialiste Simon
plenet ne veut plus s'exprimer au sujet
d'Olivier du soft dont il a été le
colistier fin janvier le maire a indiqué
à la presse locale son opposition à la
réforme des retraites mais réaffirmer
son amitié au ministre du Travail un
ministre qui se fait discret à Annonay
voit à plusieurs semaines que les
Annonéens ne l'ont pas aperçu dans sa
vie de natale
la ville d'Olivier duchauffe alors
c'était peut-être l'un des paris aussi
d'Emmanuel Macron de faire porter cette
réforme par un ancien socialisme quand
on voit Annonay c'est un pari un peu
raté
oui mais c'est est-ce que c'est
significatif oui bon vous êtes allés
voir la CFDT la CGT par définition ils
sont contre les habitants et puis alors
de trois habitants j'aimerais connaître
leur profession sur le marché
effectivement bon bah oui tout à l'heure
si du soft qui était aux parties
socialiste quelqu'un qui était réputé
quand même assez à gauche
par le passé et élu a été Luère c'est
pas pour rien c'est parce qu'il est dans
une ville qui est quand même très ancrée
à gauche que je connais un peu bon bah
voilà effectivement
il y a quand même à chaque fois à peu
près un million de personnes dans la rue
parfois un peu moins
et dans des villes comme Annonay 8
millions 8000 habitants je crois il y a
à peu près la moitié de la population
qui défile bon bah voilà
une excellente
analyse de Jérôme Fourquet sur ce
phénomène des petites villes les débiles
moyennes qui défilent et ils montrent
quoi mais il montre que le personnel de
l'hôpital le personnel de l'éducation
nationale quand il y a un conseil
départemental du conseil départemental
bon ben voilà alors vous allez me dire
les autres
c'est le manifeste au-delà de la réforme
puisque c'est la France des services
publics en l'occurrence donc ça veut
peut-être dire aussi que le
effectivement le cafetier le
restaurateur le vendeur de fruits et
légumes n'a pas les moyens de de
s'absenter pour pour les manifester
un peu différente dans la France des
villes moyennes et dans la France des
petites villes c'est ça va au-delà de la
colère contre la réforme des retraites
moi c'est ce que j'observe maintenant
c'est évident que c'est la réforme pour
moi en fait le gouvernement a commis une
erreur dans le sens où l'analyse sur
l'ambiance sociale et sociétale du pays
et aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'il essaye
de rattraper un peu par la manche en
disant on va parler du travail on va
essayer les la semaine de 4 jours etc le
droit à la déconnexion tous ces sujets
qui sont essentiels et qu'il faut
remettre à plage je pense on a un droit
du travail qui n'est pas du tout adapté
en fait à la société dans laquelle on a
c'est à dire que on n'a pas pris en
compte les nouvelles formes de travail
et en plus de ça avec deux ans de covid
donc honnêtement faire une réforme qui
s'apparente à une réforme des années 90
de droite très classique je pense que
c'est aussi ça qui bloque en fait c'est
pas seulement
la réforme qui a été proposée par le
gouvernement et c'est ça d'ailleurs son
grand or au gouvernement c'est qu'il est
passé d'une je dirais d'un profil de
réforme à l'autre était tout aussi
repoussée qui était finalement bah oui
qui était davantage peut-être AD à ce
que vous dites avant le covid
un peu un manque de de sens un peu de
flair politique c'est-à-dire que avant
le covid vous avez quand même le mois le
plus important des grèves SNCF ATP on se
souvient de Paris bloqué en fin 2019
juste avant le le confinement et une
réforme en effet qui aujourd'hui
paraîtrait presque plus juste en tout
cas la CFDT était potentiellement avec
Édouard Philippe à l'époque etc donc
moins plus facile à faire passer et pour
autant qu'il n'a qu'il n'a pas pu passer
en raison du covid mais aussi parce
qu'il y a un 49-3 a été pris à l'époque
donc on peut se dire que deux ans plus
tard trois ans plus tard c'est presque
encore pire comme période en fait pour
pour la faire passer je trouve
j'en sais rien moi et puisqu'on peut
rappeler aussi c'est que pendant la
crise du covid il y a une véritable
prise de conscience de ce qu'on appelle
les travailleurs de la deuxième ligne on
entendait notamment des membres du
gouvernement et bien saluer le travail
parfois difficile à des horaires
compliquées de ces femmes de ménage de
ces caissiers de ces infirmières et pour
faire un lien avec le débat qui en ce
moment au Sénat hier il y avait un débat
sur justement la participation des plus
aisées du capital pour rééquilibrer les
finances de notre régime de retraite et
ce que disait la gauche au gouvernement
et à la droite c'est n'oubliez pas ce
que vous avez dit pendant la crise du
covid vous et bien saluer c'est
travailleurs de la deuxième ligne et là
et bien cette réforme elle va porter
l'effort peut-être plus fortement sur
ces travailleurs qui ont commencé tôt
alors que des cadres ne sont même pas
concernés par cette réforme car ils vont
forcément aller à 65 ans mais avec le
système justement d'une carrière longue
et de la pénibilité que le néanmoins le
travail législatif est en train de
mettre en place vous savez que quatre
Français sur 6 qui aujourd'hui vont être
concernés par cette réforme c'est quand
même pas grand chose
10 pardon évidemment c'est quand même
pas grand chose et et les travailleurs
de la deuxième ligne quand comme vous le
dites il y a de grandes chances pour que
ils soient éligibles justement à des
régimes je dirais particulier et qui ne
soit pas concernés par la réforme je
reviens puisqu'on va parler évidemment
de ce qui se passe au Sénat a Annonay
Olivier du saute on voit que dans
l'hémicycle c'était le cas l'Assemblée
nationale c'est le cas au Sénat Olivier
du socle il est critiqué notamment par
la gauche pour avoir retourné sa veste
est-ce que du coup ça a contribue aussi
à l'opposition à cette réforme de
l'avoir faite portée par Olivier du
somme je pense pas je pense que cette
réforme qu'elle soit portée par Olivier
dussobe ou quelqu'un d'autre le résultat
aurait été le même ça a plus crispé un
petit peu en tout cas l'assemblée je me
souviens en effet vous souvenez de ce
député socialiste qui avait repris la
question d'Olivier dussoeuvre quand il
était à gauche et qu'il se posait à la
réforme de Nicolas Sarkozy ça c'était
assez drôle et il s'en est même pas
aperçu en effet ça donne du grain à
moudre politiquement mais je pense que
ça ça reste quand même en surface je
crois que là où il s'est quand même pris
les pieds dans le tapis c'est sur les
1200 euros le fameux minimum contributif
et il n'est pas le seul ça veut dire que
le gouvernement a quand même sciemment
laissé entendre que peut-être tout le
monde ou le plus grand nombre aurait
cette réforme minimale et que là pour le
coup avec le travail de Jérôme Guedj le
travail des économistes et quand tout le
monde a commencé à se pencher
sérieusement sur cette réforme on s'est
rendu compte que c'était pas du tout le
cas et là je pense que c'est un peu pas
le péché originel parce qu'il y en
aurait d'autres mais dans une réforme
aussi difficile à faire passer c'est une
des plus difficiles à faire passer de la
5e on peut pas se permettre de faire des
approximations comme ça de communication
à mon avis faut pas prendre les gens
pour des idiots parce que ça c'est
encore pire et ça je pense qu'ils ont
peut-être perdu des points dans
l'opinion et peut-être que la
mobilisation en a gagné avec ce fameux
1200 euros j'ajoute les femmes surtout
la semaine du 8 mars ça me tient à cœur
je crois que ça quand on a fait la
grande cause du quinquennat deux fois
qu'on s'appelle Emmanuel Macron qu'on a
fait ça et qu'on fait une réforme qui
est aussi pénalisante pour les femmes
qui perdent leur trimestre de ma vernis
et c'est toujours pas rétabli à ce stade
donc un endroit qu'elles avaient
quand on voit qu'elles ont en plus les
réformes voir les pensions les plus
basses par rapport aux hommes je trouve
ça c'est pas compréhensible et
d'ailleurs on le voit dans les cortèges
que les femmes sont très mobilisées il y
a eu deux erreurs principales
là ils se sont complètement pris les
pieds dans le tapis en plus c'était pour
le coup c'était vraiment une avancée
c'était vraiment un progrès
extraordinaire de se dire qu'il y avait
plus de
1200 euros c'est quand même une petite
retraite mais que il y avait plus de
gens qui qui avait des retraites à moins
de 1000 euros quoi enfin c'était c'était
symboliquement c'était très important là
c'est vrai que c'est impardonnable bah
ça fait partie des erreurs ils en ont
commises après sur les femmes
effectivement
j'ai moins calculé que que Astrid mais
c'est vrai que j'ai l'impression que ça
va être réparé quand même si j'ai bien
compris bon on va voir mais c'est vrai
que c'est pas normal qu'il faisait
qu'ils disaient aussi fait cette cette
boulette j'ai envie de dire en tout cas
sur les femmes il y a une volonté de
réparer justement cette boulette du
gouvernement de la part de la droite
sénatoriale qui propose une surcote des
pensions à des femmes à partir de 63 ans
pour les trimestres cotisés après 63 ans
voilà si elles ont une carrière complète
donc c'est une surcotte
avec vous sur le débat au Sénat et alors
hier le Sénat il est un peu retombé dans
un monologue de la gauche face à une
droite plutôt silencieuse oui un
monologue de la gauche qu'on avait vécu
ce week-end alors hier matin les débats
étaient plutôt intéressant parce que les
sénateurs de la républicains défendaient
leurs proposition de CDI seniors pour
favoriser l'embauche des salariés de
plus de 60 ans et donc il y avait un
vrai débat droite gauche sur et bien
l'efficacité des exonérations de charge
pour favoriser l'emploi et puis dès le
début d'après-midi hier fin du débat on
est effectivement tombé dans un
monologue de la gauche les sénateurs de
gauche ont déposé des centaines
d'amendements pour augmenter les
cotisations retraite sur les entreprises
sur les hauts salaires les revenus du
capital la gauche a multiplié les prises
de parole et en face la droite c'est
muret dans un silence pour ne pas
allonger les débats alors vous allez le
voir le sénateur communiste Fabien gay a
essayé un peu de remuer ses collègues de
droite nous on
est financement on vous offre une
palette décidons et tranchant entre nous
la majorité du peuple français va vous
le redire demain avec grande force
personne ne veut travailler deux ans de
plus parce que s'il travaille et source
d'épanouissement et de liens social pour
beaucoup de travailleurs et travailleurs
les utiles et essentiels de ce pays
c'est aussi source de souffrance
psychiques et physique et donc non on ne
veut pas voler les deux plus belles
années et donc nous pensons qu'il faut
avoir un vrai débat aller arrêter
l'obstruction silencieuse débattez avec
nous et voilà la droite sénatoriale
accusée d'obstruction silencieuse c'est
un nouveau concept qui apparu dans ce
débat après l'obstruction cordiale de la
gauche sénatoriale alors ça agacé il y a
après-midi dans l'hémicycle les
sénateurs les républicains qui
bouillonnaient qui voulaient prendre la
parole mais ils ont des consignes
justement de rester silencieux pour ne
pas rallonger les débats mais ils
étaient tellement agacés qu'à un moment
un sénateur LR a pris la parole c'est
René Paul Savary le spécialiste retraite
de la droite et il a dénoncé les
amendements en cascade déposés par la
gauche pour allonger les débats écouter
et que l'effet
itif d'amendement similaire modifiant
tout simplement un petit pourcentage un
petit pourcentage de cotisations
supplémentaires et il y a des violences
déviance du débat parlementaire vous
n'expliquez pas votre amendement vous
profitez de la tribu pour faire des
effets tribunes parce que vous savez
qu'on vous regarde et effectivement les
gens nous regardent
et puis au final on n'est pas le Savary
a utilisé l'arme ultime pour provoquer
les sénateurs socialistes assez rappelé
que sous François Hollande et bien les
socialistes ont fait passer une réforme
des retraites qui allonge la durée de
cotisation à 43 annuités progressivement
jusqu'en 2035 et donc pour les Français
à l'avenir s'ils vont travailler plus
longtemps c'est à cause d'Emmanuel
Macron avec cette réforme et aussi à
cause de François Hollande donc voilà on
a eu un débat cordial mais avec des
provocations des deux côtés et le grand
retour du débat droit de gauche au Sénat
Astrid oui on dirait on dirait moi ce
que j'ai observé là dans les dernières
heures de débat c'est qu'en fait le
Sénat même le Sénat est percuté par
cette réforme des retraites on dirait
que les petites habitudes classiques
sont un petit tout petit peu bouleversé
c'est à dire que j'ai entendu David
hassouline donc pour le PS dire que en
fait ils avaient dépensé
déposer énormément d'amendements et que
pour une fois avec c'est très rare au
Sénat aucun avait été adopté il s'en est
vraiment ému et là on a fait on l'entend
dire que c'est de l'obstruction cordiale
ça reste quand même par rapport à
l'assemblée très feutrée mais c'est
intéressant c'est à dire que et il a
raison de dire on nous regarde tous les
beaucoup de médias mettaient en ligne
hier le débat c'est notorial et pas que
votre chaîne donc ça prouve que ça
intéresse vraiment les Français et en
plus l'article 7 potentiellement
contrairement à l'Assemblée va pouvoir
être débattu donc c'est intéressant bien
sûr ouais c'est ça c'est le grand retour
du débat de douche c'est l'obstruction
silencieuse contre l'obstruction
cordiale Yves au Sénat pourquoi pas oui
non mais c'est vrai que au débat au
Sénat le débat droit de gauche il a
jamais vraiment disparu puisque par
définition vous avez une majorité de
droite et vous avez une gauche qui est
quand même moins atrophiée que que dans
l'autre chambre et alors que dans
l'autre chambre vous avez quand même
faut le rappeler une majorité qui est
une majorité et parse qui vient de la
gauche et de la droite donc c'est normal
que le débat se focalise plus sur ce
débat là sur ce cette rupture là voilà
avec des des sans doute des
personnalités qu'on davantage
d'arguments
qui sont moins dans le jeu que
dans dans la réplique
construite je dirais et puis il faut
préciser aussi que dans ces débats il y
a un alignement entre la droite
sénatoriale et le gouvernement c'est
quasiment le même le même camp c'est à
dire que les sénateurs LR restent
silencieux et à leur place et bien c'est
Gabriel Attal qui en tant que ministre
et bien lui doit donner son avis sur les
amendements et donc il utilise des
arguments qui sont aussi défendus par la
droite sénatoriale et le temps fort de
cette réforme c'est donc pour
aujourd'hui un examen de l'article 7 sur
le report de l'âge légal de départ jour
de mobilisation c'était ce que voulait
notamment la gauche sénatoriale la
mobilisation du coup va avoir un impact
sur ce qui va se passer en séance au
Sénat selon vous Astrid non je crois pas
parce que de ce que j'ai compris en
regardant le rapport de force au Sénat
on n'a pas vraiment de suspense je pense
sur la l'adoption de de cet article 7
qui décalage légal en revanche ce qui
est sûr c'est que le fait que la
mobilisation arrive avant a priori
puisque c'est fin d'après-midi je pense
que c'est mieux pour le mouvement social
parce que si le vote était intervenu par
exemple ce matin c'est toujours à mon
avis certains comptes à cette théorie à
mon avis quand le Parlement s'exprime et
en l'occurrence accepte par exemple ce
report de l'âge légal ça peut atténuer
la mobilisation beaucoup de gens qui se
disent déjà on le voit dans les sondages
d'ailleurs que les gens se disent que
cette réforme va passer mais qu'en plus
il y a une forme de tampon parlementaire
qui valide bah ça aide pas pour le
mouvement social à mon avis et c'était
la stratégie de la gauche sénatoriale
d'attendre la manifestation pour que
soit examiné cette pratique pour ne pas
pour ne pas fait bien le mouvement oui
mais bon ça va pas avoir beaucoup
d'incidences je pense on va voir je
crois pas que les sénateurs se laissent
intimider par le mouvement social et et
vice-versa
ce sont deux mouvements qui avancent de
façon parallèle
et qui ont pas réussi aujourd'hui encore
à
croisé je dirais et ça va être
intéressant de savoir si un jour il se
croise parce que si un jour il se croise
ça voudra dire que l'opposition ce
muscle mais est-ce que
contrario le fait que cet article 7 soit
voté parce qu'effectivement il y a assez
peu de suspense au Sénat quelques heures
après une mobilisation qui s'annonce
forte ça peut renforcer le sentiment des
manifestants et des opposants qui ne
sont pas entendus certains d'entre eux
oui peut-être ça peut même
durcir le mouvement on va voir moi je
veux pas
je parle Madame Irma mais c'est sûr que
ça peut durcir le mouvement
et à ce moment-là on sait pas trop où ça
conduit tout ça
oui je pense et surtout il faut voir
combien de personnes seront dans la rue
parce que vous avez beaucoup de
ministres des poids lourds qui vous
disent honnêtement il y a 3 millions de
gens dans la rue la réforme on l'oublie
tout de suite donc là on en est pas du
tout là mais moi je trouve un peu
étonnant ce qui arrive à faire des
prévisions
de la mobilisation on verra ce soir mais
ça va être très important de voir où ça
en est en fait la clé elle est aussi là
c'est à dire si vraiment il y a
énormément de gens dans la rue des
records absolus etc
que l'article 16 soit voté ou non ou
Sénas moi je pense qu'au contraire ça
peut ne rien changer c'est-à-dire qu'au
contraire la grève continue et les gens
se mobilisent de plus en plus jusqu'à
quand jusqu'à mais ça veut dire qui va
craquer c'est ça la question elle est
restée très ferme depuis le début des
mobilisations ça veut dire que s'il y a
une forte mobilisation une très forte
mobilisation elle pourrait être moins
ferme on l'a déjà vu dans l'histoire
enfin genre on prend la loi le Juppé et
les manifestations 95 on prend le CPE
enfin c'est déjà arrivé qu'un
gouvernement qui est toujours dit non
non on va tenir ne tiennent plus
d'ailleurs là par rapport au projet
initial et par rapport à la promesse de
campagne d'Emmanuel Macron on grandit
quand même un peu loin de de cette
réforme c'est à dire que on sait même
plus si on va être à l'équilibre en 2030
donc il y a déjà eu des reculs
finalement il y a déjà eu des
concessions et c'est aussi là-dessus que
par les syndicats et c'est quelque chose
qu'on envisage du côté de l'exécutif et
vous le disent pas comme ça mais il y a
une crainte
[Musique]
les deux sont des fusibles si on a un
qui va reculer et qui va qui doit
reculer en dernière sorte ça sera le
président de la République et comme
d'ailleurs Chirac avait reculé en 95
c'est pas Juppé qui avait reculé
aussi que combien même le Sénat à votre
s cet article 7 le parcours
parlementaire de cette réforme est loin
d'être terminée car donc admettons que
normalement sans trop de suspens la
majorité de droite du Sénat va voter cet
article 7 il faut encore que le Sénat
vote au final sur l'ensemble de cette
réforme des retraites ça ça va se jouer
dimanche avec une gauche sénatoriale qui
va appuyer sur le frein pour rallonger
le plus possible les débats et empêcher
qu'il y a un vote final sur ce texte
ensuite il y aura la commission mixte
paritaire c'est à dire que cette députée
cette sénateurs vont s'enfermer dans une
salle pour se mettre d'accord sur une
version commune de cette réforme des
retraites et là on a entendu la
rapporteur Elisabeth Doisneau ce matin
dire que ce n'était pas du tout sûr
qu'il y en accord entre les deux
chambres sud sur cette version commune
de la réforme des retraites s'il n'y a
pas d'accord ça retourne à l'Assemblée
nationale on a vu les déballations
Nationales c'est très peu probable qu'il
y a un vote final en de seconde lecture
en dernier mot sur cette réforme des
retraites et s'il n'y a pas de votre
finale ça veut dire que le gouvernement
passerait soit au 49-3 soit au 47 ans
article de la Constitution et donc une
réforme des retraites par ordonnance
donc avec les fortes manifestations une
forte mobilisation ça deviendrait
compliqué pour l'exécutif c'est pas fini
y compris au Parlement non c'est pas
fini effectivement c'est sûr que si ça
ça se complique sur le terrain
législatif
ça donne du grain à moudre à la
manifestation aux manifestation c'est
évident bon on va voir
les informations effectivement sur cette
commission mixte paritaire qui serait
moins simple et facile que prévu je sais
pas j'ai pas d'informations là-dessus
donc je vais pas m'avancer je pensais
que moi c'était au contraire assez
acquis que cette commission mixte
paritaire avaliserait le principe de la
loi mais bon c'est peut-être pas le cas
il y avait une forme de scepticisme
modélisabeth Doisneau ce matin après
regardez bien sûr notamment peut-être
par rapport à LR est-ce que ce sont les
LR qui détiennent la clé on a vu des
divergences entre l'air du Sénat elle a
l'air de l'Assemblée bien sûr et puis
surtout en plus de détenir la clé ils
sont en train de faire une réforme alors
sauce c'est ce qu'a dit très clairement
Bruno Retailleau nous on va faire une
réforme de droite en réponse au Parisien
et Olivier dussoll qui disait nous c'est
une réforme de gauche c'était assez la
formule était assez amusante mais elle
est toute très vraie c'est à dire qu'ils
sont en train presque de dénaturer la
réforme ils ont déjà obtenu les 64 ans
ils ont déjà obtenu les carrières
longues les concessions sur carrière
longue si ils obtiennent en plus sur les
femmes et là ce CDI senior auquel le
gouvernement dont le gouvernement ne
voulait pas c'est la réforme de du Sénat
de edlr de Monsieur Retailleau bien sûr
ça veut dire que le va être obligé de
céder à Bruno Retailleau ça c'est ce qui
se passe déjà dans les votes ils ne sont
qu'une vingtaine les macronistes au
Sénat et c'est ça que je trouve
d'ailleurs très intéressant dans la
période c'est la force de nos
institutions qui sont pleines de
surprises c'est-à-dire que non mais
c'est vrai c'est la compensait que
l'Assemblée nationale on s'en était plus
ou moins sortis puisque en réalité
personne ne voulait ni les insouminer la
République enfin ni les marcheurs ne
voulait aller à cet articles du report
de l'âge légal et aujourd'hui c'est le
Sénat à majorité de droite qui l'emporte
quand bien même ça candidate à la
présidentielle Valérie Pécresse ça fait
4 %. c'est un retournement de situation
assez fabuleux d'être en position de
force comme ça pour et ça nous laisse
des débats passionnants Yves on regarde
la Une du Figaro je vous laisse la
commenter il nous reste quelques
secondes
déterminante pour eux si effectivement
ils n'arrivent pas à mobiliser
aujourd'hui je doute qu'il puisse
mobiliser par le dans le futur donc
c'est c'est tout à fait important de le
de le signaler que ce rendez-vous est
important et pour eux et que le Figaro
est accessible sur
son site internet comme vous savez il y
a pas de journaux aujourd'hui et c'est à
dire évidemment sur l'appli et sur le
site internet merci beaucoup illustrade
d'avoir été avec nous merci beaucoup
Astrid de Vilaine ravi de vous recevoir
dans ce club Alex merci d'avoir été là
et évidemment demain édition spéciale
consacrée à l'examen de cet article 7
qui débute donc cet après-midi au Sénat
et que vous pourrez suivre bien sûr en
direct jusqu'au bout de la nuit qu'en
tant qu'amener va veiller très tard pour
vous faire suivre tout ça on se retrouve
dès demain matin pour en parler très
bonne journée
[Musique]